I think that education is a liberator if
you have a good education you could do
anything that you want and I believe
everyone ought to have that opportunity
my name is Beverly wheeler and I am a
proud graduate of Carnegie Mellon
University I'm indeed a loyal Scott and
I did my undergraduate work at Carnegie
Mellon in from H and SS and social and
decision scientists and I got my masters
in management public policy from the
Heinz college I'm currently the
president and CEO of Center City public
charter schools we have six schools
across the city 1300 kids pre-k through
eight and I've come there by using my
Carnegie Mellon skills I've worked for
every mirror and elected mayor in
Washington DC and I also was the state
executive director of the State Board of
Education from the District of Columbia
so I've had a lot of opportunities do
policy and to do research and it's all
because of what I learned at Carnegie
Mellon University
at Carnegie Mellon you learn a lot of
separate skills and you learn a lot of
things so I learned computer science i
learned economics i learned operations
research the Hinds College really brings
it all together for you so you know what
to do with those things the other thing
is we are all driven by data
particularly at Carnegie Mellon we're
driven by data but at the highest
college in a Carnegie Mellon as a whole
we don't use just we don't collect data
just to collect data we really are
impacting lives and impacting policy and
that's the wonderful thing about it it's
it's not theory it really is very
practical you can come in come out and
you're making a difference in the world
it doesn't get any better than that we
have professors that are cutting edge
they are doing things that no one else
is doing so I sort of want us to be the
quiet little place that we are but we
are changing the world and people know
it and so that's why I just I mean I
just absolutely loved it so I always
come back I try to make sure that I give
and then I participate whenever possible
and any student that calls I will talk
about the Heinz college on a regular
basis I love it
you